in September it would have been 30 years
since the premiere of The Oprah Winfrey
Show it would have been 30 years oh yes
I know I'm Oprah Winfrey and welcome to
the very first national Oprah Winfrey
shop I don't think you're woman who
lives with a lot of regret but do you
ever look back and say should I have
thirty years I never wanted to be the
person for whom people were saying that
[ __ ] was so good two years ago to be the
person who you should have gotten out of
the ring before you got punched though I
never wanted to be the person who didn't
know when to exit the party
it was the glorious most amazing
platform anybody can have to speak to
millions of people every day
and I think I exited it at exactly the
right moment I won't say goodbye I'll
just say until we meet again to God be
the glory
now I get to tell stories in a different
way what we're doing on green leaves
every week and what we're doing at Queen
sugar telling these stories of real
people in who have live ordinary lives
that become extraordinary because of
what it just means to be human